hi welcome to the data science with
statistical analysis system or SAS
course offered by simply learned in this
video you'll see some interesting
highlights of this course have you faced
challenges during data processing
because of the size of the data have you
felt the need to combine separate
compare and extract data based on a
specific requirement as interpreting
data been difficult because you couldn't
manipulate it have you ever wanted to
learn the most in-demand analytics
technology SAS can help you achieve all
this and more it offers a variety of
data analysis tools that can deal with
large data SAS provides an in - in
solution for the entire analytic cycle
it's the undisputed leader in the
commercial analytics space SAS is an
integrated system of software solutions
which enables you to perform the
following tasks data entry retrieval and
management report writing and graphics
design statistical and mathematical
analysis business forecasting and
decision support operations research and
project management applications
development the data science is
concerned with organizing packing and
delivering data SAS can help in all
three stages with the tools at their
disposal in SAS data scientists can
organize analyze and provide
interpretations or results SAS has an
edge over other tools with its huge
array of statistical functions
user-friendly graphical user interface
and technical support industries that
use SAS include automotive banking
capital markets consumer goods defense
health care higher education
manufacturing media retail sports
entertainment and so on demand for SAS
professionals has increased dramatically
compared to other data analysis software
professionals if you are someone who is
interested in the field of data science
and analytics then this course is ideal
for you all you need is an analytical
bent of mind and the rest is taken care
of by the data science with SAS course
it covers the essentials of statistical
techniques and basics of programming
using this tool
simply learns data science with sass
course will enable you to understand the
role of data scientist use the sass tool
apply data manipulation and optimization
techniques work on advanced statistical
concepts like clustering linear
regression and decision trees apply data
analysis methods to real-world business
problems understand and apply predictive
modeling techniques this course enables
you to learn the key concepts of sass
which are important for data analytics
using practical examples attention
people simply learn provides an exciting
range of learning modules for our eager
learners sass being a statistical course
simply learn provides content with
visualization to enhance learning takes
you on the syntax classroom to teach you
the coding once to hold your attention
by providing logical breaks in the form
of knowledge checks and provides
hands-on experience with demos
assignments and practice sessions going
one step further simply learn introduces
gaming to add an element of challenge to
your learning learn while you play
organize to analyze the course comprises
32 hours of instructor-led training 24
hours of e-learning and hands-on
experience with industry projects you'll
receive full support from the simply
learned faculty throughout the course
and mentoring for project work you'll
also be able to access three sets of
assessment papers and for live industry
projects on the SAS tool unsuccessful
completion you'll receive and experience
a certificate to complete data science
with SAS certification you'll need to
complete any one project and get them
evaluated by the lead trainer score at
least 80% on the online exam submit your
queries by writing to help and support
on WW simply learn comm or talking
directly to our support staff with the
simply talk and a live chat options go
ahead and begin data science with SAS
course the first lesson is analytics
overview happy learning